Oh, good morning everyone.
Welcome to the Advanced Data Binding Lecture
I am Yigit Boyar.
I am George Mount.
We are from the Android UI Toolkit team
Part of the Android Architecture team
Today, let's talk about data binding.
Ok
How many of you have used data binding in the past?
How many people think that it is still in the testing stage?
it is good
Well, this is the problem.
We didn't make a big announcement last fall.
When we release it with Android Studio
Now available
Welcome everyone to use it
It is very high quality
It performed very well in the public beta
So if you haven't seen it yet, I have a link here.
This link is about before in the Android Developer Summit
Video about Android data binding
You just have to click here
If you watch at home,
You can click on it now
Pause the video, check out this link
Because we are about to show you a lite version of about four minutes.
This includes everything from just 40 minutes.
It is very good
Ok
So what is data binding?
When we have such a layout
This is my store
And what I want to do is -- because
I certainly want to load data in the layout.
Of course, I have to find
View in my layout
Then set all the data, right?
This is terrible, right?
I hate doing these
So we use Android data binding
Let's take a look at that layout again.
Ok, we have to get rid of all the setting logic
These settings are very troublesome
FindViewByID is really bad.
But we have to do some different settings
In onCreate
We don't call setContentView
We must have a different setContentView
This will create a data binding
Then we have to set the data target on that binding.
But we can't just do these
We have to adjust a little bit of our layout.
First, add a layout label
Outside of this
Of course, we have to move the namespace to the position of the layout label.
Because that's the right thing
We still have a data tag
That tag has all the variables we want to use.
Here, for the production of our products
It helps us import and load variables
So that we can use it in the layout
We also need to quote them
So we add the value directly to our reference source
Or other elements already in our layout
Now you can see that we can use any expression
We can use @{ to mark this as a data binding tag.
Let's take a look at how it works.
Data integration is really amazing
And you need a brief explanation
It can be even more amazing
For example, there are standardized steps to tell us
How to prepare, it is important to know this
So you can know what happened behind the scenes
If you are having trouble
You will have a clue where is the problem?
When you click "Run" in Android Studio
Android Studio will start assembling your app
And merge your resources
When layout files are merged
We can choose those layout files
Then delete all the information about the data binding
So all the data you entered about data binding will be deleted.
If you add data binding information to the layout
You will lose it
Next, we parse these expressions
So their grammar is correct
But we don't know if the information you entered makes sense
But they must be grammatically correct
So when we parse, we know
Here are some identifiers here
Enter your field
We don’t know what this is at this stage.
When we know it is correct
If not correct, there will be an error report
Next, your application code will be compiled
The java code you write will be compiled
When it is compiled
We use handlers
Get the output we parse from the layout file
To understand its meaning
For example, you have a user.admin
Now you can specify your variables
We know there are some user costs here.
We find these costs
Then we have to find out what is the meaning of isAdmin
Is it a method call?
Still a field?
We found this answer
We finally liked this management method.
Or you can type user.admin
We still know that this is a
Is.admin Boolean method
Then we can understand that this grammar was expressed before
Can be parsed into a Boolean value
Now let's look at its properties
I have to know what regulator to call.
Is this an integer that can be seen, or is it enabled, can we solve this problem?
It all happened in
When the application is compiled
When we decide what we want to do, we use the code
Write data binding to update the user interface
Then you can benefit
In a nutshell, this is a data binding layout file.
We did this at compile time.
Delete all information
We try to get the file and code
Match each other as much as possible
If you view your files
You will find this file with deleted information.
So we delete the layout label
We remove all data binding settings
Because APT doesn't know them
We clean them up
Then we click on some tags so -- next, well --
When you zoom in on the layout you will know
That's why even if you didn't put the ID here
We can also find the reason for it
Here, George has some gifts for everyone.
So this is what we released in the fall.
Let's see what new features are available.
Two-way data binding
I know that I heard a lot of people say
This is really great.
Single if there is no two-way data binding
Data binding is not useful, right?
I really can't believe to hear these
Because I think one-way data binding is also very useful
I saw some people
Want to do some of their own things with two-way data binding
They did something like this
That is, they use the original data binding field for one-way data binding.
Then add another processor
To change the text
Of course, they have to check
Is there a change, otherwise
Text changes will cycle continuously
Then it will go back to the field area
And send a text change message
That’s a mess.
You will get in your layout
This change handler gives each different binding view
This is really bad
So we want a better solution
Get rid of all the methods you are used to
We can do it on our own
By using @= instead of @{, right?
@= is a very fast, easy to see indicator
This indicates that this is a two-way data binding field
Now we can use a very simple method
Bind Android text fields
Now, you might wonder how this notification is implemented.
What is the operation behind it?
This is very important
If you want to write your own data binding fields
First of all, we have to know
Which monitor to add
We won't want to use TextWatcher
Because this is only valid for text viewing and editing
We don't want to use -- I don't know, what?
Time change
Yes, date changes, etc.
That is bad
So we have some general purpose monitors
Reverse binding listener
It will tell you
Changed in your view
Your binding will be for you
Install this listener
These codes are generated directly by the generated code program.
You can see what happened here
Is it gets the text from the view
Then it did an empty test
You must make sure that you do all the empty detection.
Everyone here has to look at your variables over and over again.
right?
Ok?
everyone?
Yes
I know
You are not using data binding
You don't need an empty test
Yes
It is 2016
Yes, right
Who has not had an abnormal pointer?
I do not know
nobody
what language?
Finally it sets the field
You can see that the field is set to
Observable field
In fact, you may be interested to see
Because this comment is in the generated code
So if you want to see the generated code,
You will see this comment
And see the inverse of this expression
To help you debug if you have problems
So let's see how you get the field value
We just saw -- get the field value
One thing we need to do to annotate the fastest comment
This can give your view an absorber
Here we have a text view type
We want to know what is the absorber for android:text.
Now we have this method
We can declare it
It's called getText
But if you don't set it it is a default setting
It only uses attribute names
Even if we don't set any properties it will use getTest
Because the property is android:text
It’s very wise to do this
And we have this comprehensive attribute
This is for this event
This event push notification
Tell us what has changed in the view
Once again, there are default settings there.
If we have not set
It will be android:textAttrChanged
Most of the time, you won't be making any settings here.
Now, I want to talk more about this aspect.
Of course, we have to go from the text view
Get notified
This is what you usually do with the text view.
You will set a TextWatcher
We have the properties of this event
In the binding debugger
So we just added another attribute
Comprehensive attribute
Now, this comprehensive attribute - you
Can't be used in your layout
We will check it
If you try to do this
It will give you an exception or error message
Anyway, you can now set this in your binding adapter.
Of course, all are set for you.
All fields that can run
Of course, what do you need to do?
You need to remove the previous adapter
Then add a new one
You just need to inform them if they are not null, right?
We don't want to notify the empty value of things
Because we want to do null detection
Then we also need to notify our onChange
So now, we know that when the text view changes
It will call the generated onChange
If you have a more complicated absorber -- but
This is not very complicated, just a little more complicated.
This text view does not return a string, what does it return?
Yes
Character sequence, right?
Who uses the character sequence here?
Oh, no one uses character sequences
If you want to set the character sequence to a string?
Type conversion error
So this will be convenient
You have a getTextString
It will automatically convert your character sequence to a string
This can help you
Again, we have this property
Other character fields are also there - that event
Are default settings
We mentioned these loops before.
That is if you have a text view, or edit the text
It will make changes, of course --
It will change your data field
If your data field has changed
Will change your [inaudible]
This is really bad. Because what happened?
The user enters A, but it displays the text again on it.
And you lost your cursor
Oh!
Yes, you will realize this
If you set the text in the text view it will become the same text
It is still called a change listener
It will have the same layout
Because in the internal [inaudible] is actually a
[inaudible] string
It has some other formats so we have to do this
Yes
So we have already talked about data binding
What do you think?
Actually
It can do more
Because it just realized that there is another change
Of course, it will send another text change
Will continue to last
This is really bad
No one likes an infinite data binding loop
Let us solve this problem
We will solve this problem completely, right?
Unfortunately, can't
But you can solve this problem
We solve this problem for all the settings already applied.
You only need to check the binding adapter
When we set a text field we look at the previous value
Make sure it has not been changed
If it is changed then we need to set it up
If it hasn't been changed, we don't have to set it up.
This can be obtained in our
Break the loop before the infinite loop
This is what we are in data binding
Solution used
Changing the architecture is an option
But only valid for new devices
By doing these workarounds, can we support data binding API 7?
API 7, yes.
Are all the properties valid?
no
of course not
Because we need events
We need events to know if the field has been changed
Whether the attribute has been changed
So we only do
There are change events such as TextWatcher
Like CheckedChanged
These are external events
These are not in any change event
Fortunately
Basically, all the events you care about have changed notices.
These are the things that users will click, right?
They type in the edit field
So this is very good
We have already notified these events
This time for almost all the attributes you care about
Both are effective
But if you have your own fusion
You need to do this to set up an external event
For monitoring
Ok
Let's talk about link expressions
Here, I have a layout with three views
They all have the same expression
These codes are ugly
For example, all UI code is a bit ugly.
I really don't want to do this.
I want to write the code once and then it can be reused elsewhere.
I can create an ID
So I can use it in other expressions
Now I can bind to another field
really not bad
After the back, what it does is of course, just that I am talking
Oh, I realize this.
We have a lot of expressions there
I will replace it
We also have implied event updates
For example, you combine a check field in another view.
Because the check is a two-way data binding field
So we can say oh, look, the field there is
-- the user clicked on it
We will receive updates soon
We know what happened
Let's talk about lambda expressions
So two-way data binding
Is from the layout
A way to use data in your data model
Another method is callback
Callback is to get a view
You set a click list
We want to do this better.
Two days before we introduced this feature
For data binding
You will give the event an ID
In your Java code
You will get an ID from the binding
We have created a view for you
Then you will set up a ClickListener
We want to make everything intuitive
We got rid of it
We applied the method reference so you can say
Hey, we know that OnClick is an event.
So where does this Presenter come from?
[inaudible] and other variables you quoted
So there is still no magic here.
This is not like your activity in the architecture.
OnClick event used
In the Presenter, what you have to do is
Call this method
We will receive the view because onClick
As long as it receives the view, you can get the binding
This is a cool way
Just like data binding, it has a findBinding method
In any view
You can get the event there
Then do whatever you want
But this is still a lot of unnecessary code
So we want to simplify it
We introduced lambda expressions
Come get rid of it
You can set this when onClick happens
Call the presenter.save of the project
Where does the project come from?
This is the project you announced there.
So use the same method in the presenter
You can do whatever you want because you have that project
This is very cool -- in fact
Why do we want to promote it -- so we added this to the time bar
We promoted this feature earlier
Because the test team
These framework demos were released via Google
They want similar features
When you do this, presenter doesn't have any Android code.
So your layout file handles all events for Android
You can test your presenter the way you want.
This is a beautiful separation
It is very useful and very refreshing
Another cool thing is in today's Android Studio.
You can slide to the same function and click on it
Then open the Presenter
This makes it easier for us to find code during development.
So to see [? list?] get more details
This is a lambda expression
You can also write it
onClick can receive a view
If you look at the course description of the onClick callback function
It looks like this
You can reference this view in a lambda expression
If you want to use it
Then the view inside the expression will reference
That you declared in the parameters section
So, just like Java, eight lambda functions
At least you have -- actually you can
Feel free to name
So I call it v. The name doesn't need anything more to match
Let's look at another example, FocusChange
So you want to know when FocusChange happens
You want to call your presenter based on the latest focus
Unfortunately, you can't do this
Because if you look at FocusChange
Or FocusChange syntax, this method accepts the view
And the state of focus
So even if you don't want to use view syntax,
You still need to define the v parameter
So the rule is either you declare all the parameters that the method will receive.
Or nothing defined
We found nothing defined [inaudible]
Is very common
For example, in ClickListener you almost never want to [inaudible]
[inaudible]
So we want to provide you with no-parameter shortcuts.
Another example is onLongClick
The difference between onLongClick is
It expects the result to be a Boolean value
So we know if we want to fill it
To make this workable
Presenter has a lot of methods -- you also need to return a Boolean value
So we won't -- if you enter some lambda expressions there
It won't give back the value that the callback function wants
It won't compile.
We don't want, you know, oh, this, by default, will give back the wrong value.
If something breaks in the future? ? ?
You won't know
If you can't match, we won't try anything.
We failed
There are two ways to achieve the same effect
That is, lambda expressions and method references
They are very useful
I want to talk about how they differ.
Because they have different effects
The main difference between the two methods is that
Lambda expressions will be evaluated
When the event occurs
So no matter what expression you enter here
We will evaluate it when the user clicks on the button,
Or when the text changes, or other
Method reference
Is evaluated when the UI is refreshed
When it is evaluated when we refresh the UI
We evaluate expressions
We find the method that needs to be called
And set the ClickListener that can directly refer to [inaudible]
Let's look at an example
Make everything clearer
In the previous example we have a presenter
I set it to null
And the presenter--
Link the same method to the same button
If we take a look at saveButton.getClickListener
In this example, when the presenter is null
Is the same button a ClickListener?
If you use a lambda expression, it won't
It actually still has the same button
But not null
Even if you don't have a presenter
There is a callback in this view
But if you use the method reference, it will be null
We don't need to set it
Sometimes setting a clickable view has side effects
This is very important to you.
You need to use the method reference
But we will deal with [inaudible]
So even if there is a callback you won’t crash
When the callback [inaudible]
We will find no presenter
It will deprecate it
So its way of doing it is when you zoom in on the layout --
If you don't use a lambda expression we will zoom in on the layout
We set the ClickListener
It belongs to us
When the user clicks we evaluate the presenter
We evaluate the parameters and then run it
If you use method reference
When we will perform the binding this is what we generated
And how to update the UI
When we run that method we will find the presenter
If there is a presenter
We will bind it to the listener, which is the related method.
If there is no presenter, we will set the callback to null.
The listener syntax we generated
It looks so simple
It accepts presenter
So we compare it to the reference
Then we can call it back
The presenter comes from our evaluation presenter
Another difference is that you can use expressions
This is the information we get from lambda expressions
You can use any expression in the lambda
And you can't do this in a method expression
So you can type presenter.save(user.friend)
Then we will evaluate it
Or you can type data.presenter
Any valid expression in data binding can be used here
We will evaluate it
You can't do this in a method expression.
Method must match the event
You can enter data.presenter in the same way.
You can use an expression in one open
But you can't change the call parameters
That callback parameter -- in both methods
We can all use it
If you use a presenter
You have to set the parameters yourself
Like I want to use the view
You need to set the parameters
I am sorry
Wrong button
If you use the reference method it is already feasible
It must match the event
Now in a lambda expression
You can use an extra few variables that you couldn't use before.
One of them is view IDs
Ok?
You can refer to your view in the expression.
This is your view ID, it has been referenced
It is called the camel-casified version.
This is the same field you used in the binding
So we bind it as before.
You can also use the context
I know that many of you want it.
You can see the context without seeing a specific view
So we only give you the context of the root
You can think of it as a generated, synthetic variable
And can be used directly in your layout
But if you create a context
We won't do this
Yes, don't do that
Please don't do that
It will cover our context
If you do that then
Ok, let's talk about animation.
Animation
Everyone wants to use animation in their user interface
How many people, please raise your hand
Yay!
This is right, this is right [inaudible]
action
Let your user interface move
For data binding, you will find
It does not require special operations
You will get this strange result
When you click on some button it will snap to its position
This is really unfortunate.
But we can use some simple operations to get better animations.
That is overuse
How many of you have used excessively before
Transition function was introduced in KitKat
Very useful
You can use it to get automatic animation
You can add onRebindCallback
One of the functions is onPreBind
This is what we really care about.
This will be evaluated before binding
Before the binding is evaluated
We don't know what will happen
We only know
Something happens when it is called
What we have to do is we bring the sceneRoo
Call beginDelayedTransition
Then you can get a very good effect
very good
Very convenient
very simple
Maybe we should make it an API
Enable animation
this is a good idea
Yes, we should do this
But this is not effective under any circumstances
Let me see this ad here.
When we change the fields here
Change the user’s age ad will still jump in and out
Ok, our transition system
Can't handle all the transitions you want
It can handle most common situations -- shallow and shallow
Or change the position of the view, and so on.
You can also use your own transition
Sometimes you want personalized settings
You just want to make an animation for it.
What should you do?
In this case, we can use the settings
When the value is set in the field
We can get the state in the relevant field and turn it into an animation.
So we created the BindingAdapter
We can get old and new values
You can not use the old value if you don't want it.
In this example, we want to use the old value.
Of course, if nothing has changed, we must use the old value.
Of course, don't do anything
We don't want to do anything if nothing has changed
Then, we can make the animation in that place, that place
You can do any animation you want
I don't know, what do you want to do with the text field?
But you can do anything here
Such as cross-fade
I do not know
Dependency injection
Ok
Everyone raises their hands
How many people like dependency injection?
Ok
Good
it is good
This is what you want
This is for you.
When you write the test, of course, what do you do?
When you are binding the adapter you have a if statement
If it is a test setup or you are not testing the setup
You can do this or another
But we are fans of dependency injection
We don't want to
This is very bad
So what we have to do is create an adapter
This is no longer static.
So we have an abstract binding adapter
Of course, this could be an interface
It does not need to be an abstract base class
We use your test version or product version
Implant this interface
But we don't know which interface to call.
We are doing data binding
We don't know if you want
Called in your beta or product version
So we need to know what you will do
So we created this data binding component
Whenever we see an instance method like this
I know you will give us an instance.
So you implant this component
This is a generated data binding component
Generated a getter in it
And you implanted it
You will do everything possible to get your components
However, you still need to set it up
This is the default setting
You can also use it in every inflated call.
But maybe you just want to use one of them
You can use it every time you inflate a view, or bind a view
When you are statically binding an adapter
You can also use it
You don't have to do it
Do this when the instance binds the adapter
Now, I want to give you a useful example of it.
We have this system for loading a picture
We want to use the image loader to load the image
We already have a cache
We certainly get the ImageLoader instance
Of course, got the component
So where does the component come from?
We can take the context
Then we can try to find it in the context
By casting it, and [inaudible]
This is a bit of pain
So what we can do is
Introducing data binding components
Of course, this is in our application
Some examples
We can introduce it in the BindingAdapter
Then we can use it
If you use Dagger 2 you need to create a module
And provide a method
Then you can create a component
Then set your default component like this
Ok
Also, if you use data binding
But never set up binding adapters and use them
This is really great
You can set your own properties
I saw a lot - like, we have to create them
So we can use data binding
But in fact, the data binding function is the most widely abused.
This is a good thing, the characteristics of data binding
The main problem we got was
How do we get started with data binding?
Because you already have an app
When you start from scratch, yes, it’s easy
If you already have an app
It's illogical to rewrite your layout
This is unnecessary work
Keep it if possible
But in the new layout, you can start using data binding.
We want to talk about these levels in detail.
So to start using data binding you just need to enable it in Gradle
very simple
Three lines of code
One thing you can do today is in any layout.
You can build [inaudible]
There are 25, or 30 databases
I have to find a way to get [inaudible]
There are now 31
Yes
31 is the last one
After we release the data binding
I didn't see people who created it.
This is the function we should release seven years ago.
Even eight years ago
When we released Android
So you add layout tags to your layout.
This is fine
You don't need to do anything else
Now, with your code you have these findViewById
Or have these comments you added to the view
You can get rid of all this now
You can get this binding category in this layout.
It already has all the views that view has an ID to use as the field
This is what the public knows, the last field
They are security type fields
You don't need casting
If you make a mistake -- there is a very common mistake that will happen --
Are you using the same ID
In different places, in different layouts
If someone changes the ID in one place
Your code won't crash,
Because the same ID is still used in another place
But it will crash at runtime
Because you can't find the view.
This does not happen through data binding
Because we create bindings for each layout
If someone accidentally changed the ID
It won't compile
The second part is the binding user interface.
This is a very simple way you can start using data binding
In fact, you should do this
In my opinion, this is very clumsy. Of course, I am biased.
You have this in every user interface --
Like your presenter
When you enter data you view your data
View your views and make settings for each of them
You need to handle null values
No, you need to capture them
nonsense
This is what you need to write
Unnecessary code
You don't need to write it
So just delete these IDs
Set your variables in the layout
This is a layout showing detailed information
Just use intuition
Set the amount of input in the layout
You can say that the user is displayed in this layout.
You set it up and use it inside
So when someone inflates your layout
And want [inaudible] they have used the binding syntax
They can see all the processors
They know what the input of the layout is.
[inaudible] update the user interface method to get rid of everything
What you need to do is just set it in the binding
Then apply it
All of this will not affect performance
The third point is the callback
Sometimes, you use to bind and get the settings
Then set the ClickListener
This is also unnecessary
Just set presenters
Call this method when the button is clicked
The best thing about this feature is
When you are in Android Studio -- it always happens
You enter the layout
Ok, if the user clicks
Your attempt to search for a view ID
Then find where the ClickListener is
There are several steps
Here you can click and use this method
Then find the implementation
If you start using a new app
Observability may be very, very useful
So used to replace this simple user syntax
You can extend BaseObservable
If you don't want to expand, there is an interface
Can let you do the binding
Whenever the value is changed
You want to find these changes
We will update the user interface
There is a new, highly recommended feature
Bidirectional data binding
Now two-way data binding when you have a complex model
Not very easy to use
But just like all of us have a login form --
All these people need to fill in
Simple form layout
There is a lot of logic here.
Here you don't need to write code
You can have two-way data binding handle it
Return your things
A layout like this, you only need [inaudible]
Create a team
Set them all to observable fields
There is only one instance of this syntax
How expensive it is not important
Set everything as an observable field
When we do this, our layout looks like this
We have real data
To enable or deprecate this button or any logic
You have this form model
You can use them for every input field
You can say this is a name
Note that this is a two-way data binding
Or you have a button
You will say that if my real data model enables it, then let it be started
You can do this
You can't do this in every layout
So you need to be careful
But there is one thing you can compress - it's all about the form
Or [inaudible] you want to get data ---
This is more convenient and simple
I can save time
So just do it
Now you have a binding layout
Let you get a data object
Then you do whatever you want with that data.
Let me introduce some best practices to you.
Because data binding is very powerful
But just because you can use data binding to do these things.
Doesn't mean you should use data binding to solve all problems
When you are using data binding
Should pay attention to the expression you enter
If you type in an expression like this
Then the user clicks on this button and pays,
You should not do this
Because this is wrong
Because the payment is completely related to your application.
It’s like your business logic
Has nothing to do with your user interface
You just care about
The user clicked on that button
The responsibility for data binding is over here.
So please get rid of it
Don't do that
You should enter presenter::onSendClick
So the presenter syntax can be self-tested
You can have a reliable application
The boundaries of use are not very clear
Where should I use data binding?
What should I use Java code?
Please use your intuition
Use the best method for you
So you are saying
To change the name of our function, right?
Yes, that is the goal
Yes, yes, good
Do not call the [inaudible] function
Use [inaudible]
This can solve it
Regardless, data binding can be used with the program
Because we did everything at the time of compiling [? Settings?] details
Another point is if it is related to the user interface
Just put it there
You don't need, oh my day
I should not put any logic in my [inaudible]
This doesn't make any sense
No matter what the layout looks like if it is simple
Just stay there because the important thing is
When you are three months later
In Android Studio, when looking at that layout file
Can you know what the role of this layout is?
This is the point
It should be illustrative
Should be able to explain themselves
But if you are here, put such an expression
You can't read it and understand what it means
This is very confusing
Do not do this
Simple expression should be used
So please get rid of it
Create a method to give a short name
And use that method
If the expression cannot be read
If you find that the expression is too long
Then you may have done something wrong
This is a method we created
We can also mention that
We can also use string functions here.
If you want to replace with a string
You can be in your expression
Use string formatting
Another feature is RecyclerView
Also, two days ago
We just released a sample application using Data Binding and RecyclerView on GitHub
RecyclerView application samples on GitHub
I sent it to the Spaces link where you can find it
What you need to pay attention to is
If you use RecyclerView with data binding
You should do this because it generates an [inaudible] for you.
When you bind a view
You should call executePendingBindings every time.
If you don't do this, it will postpone it to the next layout.
And RecyclerView does not work very well.
Because the view doesn't tell us the height
Still a few points
Here are some small examples
About how people use binding adapters most of the time
I want to mention them
you can do it
It's like HTML
We have a text view which is an image URL
This could be an imageView
But this is a text URL
This is ok
You have a binding adapter
You stick it here
Everything works well [inaudible]
Do you know what the image shows?
You do not need an ID
To make it self-explanatory
This is invisible
Oh, there is an image URL here.
You can have multiple parameters
Binding adapter can receive multiple parameters
You can say, well, this is a placeholder
This is an image URL
You have a binding adapter to receive two properties
You call it with these two values
We call it paintable, it is really paintable.
You don’t need to
You can use your logic
It tests very well because at the time of testing
You just provide a virtual adapter that doesn't do anything.
So now your test runs faster
No need to do a work request
Another point - font
This has been asked for many years in the text view
We haven't [inaudible] until the data is bound
Now you can create your own properties
Call app:font and you can run it.
There is a project on GitHub
Can do this from [inaudible]
Very cool
Very convenient
You can use the paintable vector
You can't use a paintable vector in XML right now.
right?
Do not
If you use data binding you can actually use vector images
You just create a binding adapter for that and do it.
The other one here is
Very common in applications [inaudible]
Dimension picture margin
Then you have something like the size of the dimension image
Dimensional image size and margins
You can align the view
You created all of these dimensions
You don't need much
You only need to use data binding
This thing is a picture plus a picture margin
That's it
This should already be there.
but
Ok
When you start experimenting
These are things we haven't considered yet.
Remember the image super URL
We think of one thing...that is it
Someone invented this font and margins
This is just a new thing you can do with data binding.
Please continue to explore it
thank you all
Thank you